[Music]
you grew up in Australia and you're one
of you have two brothers is that right I
have two older brothers they're two
older brothers okay and one of them is
an actor as well he played one of you
brothers played Thor he was Thor yes
thank goodness that's like that's what
they make there's something that we talk
about a vane yeah now okay did you guys
cuz in my family I have I'm one of four
brothers and we would fight all the time
and people are horrified when they hear
that because they think that that's
unusual but that's when brothers are
close in age they fight I feel like
that's when you you really get to know
each other's when you give someone a
good punch in the face it's one way of
expressing love that was how we did it
now house yeah I meant good to see you
as a punch in the face boy right how bad
would it get between you pretty bad I
mean when me and me and my older brother
never fought but me and Chris used to
fight non-stop to the point where I
remember my mum and dad went away to
Europe for three months and me my
brother Luke my oldest brother stayed at
my grandma's house and Chris had to stay
at Michael's house cuz we were too much
trouble to be together right we would
have a fist fight about who was gonna
sit in the front seat of the car I an I
flike a proper I don't know why my
grandpa thought it was a good idea to
give little kids a proper throwing knife
but he gave it to it and I wait a minute
yeah you threw a knife at your brother
like a proper throwing are you talking
about that now but you could throw it
into a tree and it would stick into the
tree I know what a knife does yeah
this kitchen knives but this one this
one is made specifically to stick into
things when you throw you can't even
throw a kitchen knife on somebody yes he
was threw a knife at your brother I
threw it at his head when I was about I
and the handle hit him in the head hold
the handle side guy yeah it was like a
warning like if you mess with me all
wrong so I did that that was we had
passed by at one time we're having a
really bad fistfight and my mum tried to
break it up but she got her finger
broken so that was kind of a low point
about fighting
I still think throwing the knife in his
hand the time he shot you first all
right so you moved to Los Angeles from
Australia big transition for you was
this like an intense yeah was it very
different here it was it was I mean was
a big move I i thankfully had Chris had
been here a couple years before I'd been
here so he'd come
you know I made friends and I had a few
friends that knew him and so you and
were there you guys have all these
exotic creatures in Australia that we
don't have do we have any exotic
creatures that you don't have there
anything that you saw here we were like
oh my god yeah the biggest thing would
was squirrels I didn't know that
squirrels wait we do not have squirrels
in Australia and I pretty I'd literally
pretty much only seen them in cartoons
yeah I did an interview and I hadn't
made a joke about some squirrels so now
I'm obsessed with squirrels I have an
obsession with screwed you see them for
the first time at the Disney lot I was
at the Disney lot I remember sitting
there I thought it was ironic that they
had squirrels running out you know the
only place I'd seen it was in pretty
much Disney cartoons right and I know
those burrows tropical looking
characters I feel like they just may
have a look on their face where they
know something that you don't that
they're planning something I don't trust
them to be honest
that's definitely something you guys
have Wallabies and kangaroos and you got
like squirrels we have what some of
those mate